pensieri in codice idee
dal mondo del software a
cura di valerio galano
salve a tutti i ragazzi
e bentornati su pensieri
in codice per la puntata
di oggi vorrei parlare
di bug noi tutti siamo
abituati ai bug nei nostri
videogame nei nostri
social o nei nostri
smartphone
tuttavia nel corso della
storia ci sono stati alcuni
bug che seppur molto piccoli
hanno causato
danni economici enormi
per questo episodio ho
quindi pensato di stilare
la lista dei 10 bug
più costosi della storia
cape canaveral la nasa
lancia il mariner one
verso venere dopo soli 290
secondi dalla partenza
la navicella inizia a
deviare dalla rotta
prestabilita la situazione
è irrecuperabile
l'ingegnere a terra è
costretto ad attivare il
sistema di autodistruzione
inizialmente si pensa
ad un sabotaggio ma ad
una seconda analisi ci
si accorge che il tecnico
che ha ricopiato il
software dal blocco note
su di un calcolatore ha
omesso un sistema di autodistruzione
per questo motivo il
software a bordo della
navicella non è stato
in grado di compensare
alcuna variazione di
velocità il costo della
navicella andata
completamente distrutta
fu
all'epoca di 18 milioni
di dollari
19 giugno 1978
connecticut il tetto del
art for coliseum è
stato scoperto da un'azienda
di autodistruzione
crolla sotto il peso di
una coltre di neve bagnata
dalle indagini emerge
che il software
cad utilizzato per la
progettazione non era in
grado di gestire più di
una variabile per volta
per questo motivo aveva
calcolato la struttura
del tetto tenendo in
considerazione solamente
il peso dei materiali stessi
fortunatamente non ci
furono vittime ma i danni
stimati furono di
oltre 90 milioni di dollari
1988 uno studente della
cornell university tale
robert morris decise di
scrivere un software
per qualcosa che definì
lui stesso un innocuo
esperimento questo
software però mandò in
crash
centinaia di computer a
causa di un errore di
codifica lo studente fu
multato per 10.000
dollari ma il costo per
sistemare i danni fu di
oltre 100 milioni di
dollari
attualmente morris è
professore al mit e il
codice del suo innocuo
esperimento è custodito
presso l'università di
boston
nel gennaio del 1990 60.000
utenti della at&t una
delle più grandi società
di telecomunicazioni
americane si trovò nell'impossibilità
di effettuare chiamate
long distance quelle che
noi conosciamo come
interurbane inizialmente
si pensava ad un hackeraggio
successivamente però ci
si rese conto che la at&t
circa un mese
prima aveva effettuato
alcune modifiche sui
propri sistemi per
incrementarne le
performance e la
velocità questo
incremento di velocità
però aveva portato a
destabilizzare il
sistema di
bilanciamento del carico
tra gli switch causando
il blocco a cascata di
tutti e 114 gli switch
disponibili le perdite
stimate per at&t furono
di circa 60 milioni di
dollari
nel 1994 fu invece il
turno di intel la nota
società produttrice di
processori lanciò sul
mercato una linea di
pentium che risentiva di
un problema nel calcolo
delle operazioni
matematiche che coinvolgevano
i numeri in virgola
mobile in pratica c'era
la possibilità di sbagliare
il calcolo della decima
cifra dopo la virgola
dopo l'insurrezione
dei consumatori la intel
si offrì di sostituire
tutti i processori a
coloro
che ne avessero fatto
richiesta così il costo
totale dell'operazione
ammontò a circa 475 milioni
di dollari
nel 1996 invece l'esa l'agenzia
spaziale europea riuscì
a battere il record del
mariner one il
responsabile a terra fu
infatti costretto a premere
il tasto di autodistruzione
in ben 36 secondi dal
lancio il software di
controllo di volo e dell'area
in five infatti tentò
di convertire un numero
in
virgola mobile a 64 bit
in un intero a 16 bit
causando il crash del
computer principale e di
quello di riserva che
era perfettamente identico
e montava lo stesso
identico software il
costo per
lo sviluppo del razzo
era stato di 8 miliardi
di dollari e inoltre esso
portava con sé come
carico un satellite del
valore di 500 milioni di
dollari 1998 di nuovo
protagonista la nasa
il mars climate orbiter
era una sonda progettata
per studiare il clima e
l'atmosfera di marte
questa
sonda avrebbe dovuto appunto
orbitare attorno al pianeta
russo
ma si schiantò sulla
sua superficie poiché
tentò di orbitare troppo
in basso dalle indagini
venne
fuori che il problema
banalmente dovuto ad un
errore di conversione
tra il sistema inglese
e quello metrico decimale
a montare del danno 125
milioni di dollari 2004
regno unito due agenzie
governative il child
support agency e il
department of work and
pensions decisero di ristrutturare
contemporaneamente i
propri sistemi informatici
i software che ne risultarono
furono talmente
incompatibili da causare
milioni di transazioni
errate sia in eccesso
che in difetto riscossioni
non effettuate e rallentamenti
burocratici il costo per
i contribuenti inglesi
ha molto a un
miliardo di dollari
nell'agosto del 2009 una
lexus e s 350 si schiantò
oltre 150 miglia orarie
causando
la morte di quattro
persone prima dell'incidente
uno dei passeggeri chiamò
il 911 dicendo che
l'auto era priva di freni
e senza controllo a novembre
dello stesso anno la toyota
dovette
richiamare 9 milioni di
auto da tutto il mondo
per correggere un bug
nel software del sistema
antibossi
bloccaggio dei freni il
costo totale stimato per
l'operazione fu di oltre
3 miliardi di dollari
nell'agosto del 2012 in
night capital group una
delle più grandi società
americane di servizi
finanziari inviò in
automatico una serie di
ordini di acquisto in
contemporanea invece che
nell'arco di giorni
così come era stato
previsto le perdite di
questa operazione furono
di ben
quattro volte superiori
a quelli di un'altra
società americana e di
un'altra società americana
l'errore fu causato da
un server all'interno
della farm che non era
stato aggiornato e pertanto
eseguiva del codice
obsoleto nell'arco di
due giorni le azioni
della società persano
ben il
75 per cento e il totale
delle perdite stimate fu
di 440 milioni di dollari
con questo siamo arrivati
alla fine della nostra
lista dei 10 bug più
costosi della storia
come abbiamo visto anche
dei minimi errori
possono provocare danni
enormi spero che l'episodio
vi sia
piaciuto e come al solito
vi invito a lasciare un
commento per farmi sapere
cosa vi è piaciuto
cosa no e se magari conoscete
voi dei bug che ho dimenticato
di inserire in questa
lista
per ora vi saluto e ci
sentiamo al prossimo
episodio di pensieri in
codice
iscriviti al canale